STEPHANIE WONG:
Today we're talking
about BigQuery, more BigQuery,
and Java for Cloud Functions.
I am Stephanie Wong, and
welcome to This Week in Cloud
where we serve you
the lowest latency
news from the safety of home.
Google Cloud Functions is an
event=driven serverless compute
platform that lets you build
and deploy applications
in a fully-managed environment,
both locally and in the cloud.
And we've just announced that we
are adding support for Java 11.
This means you can now write
Cloud Functions in Java
or in your favorite
JVM language,
such as Kotlin,
Groovy, or Scala.
Support for Java 11 is now
in beta, so try it out.
BigQuery recently turned
10, and to celebrate we're
giving it some
well-deserved attention.
In this birthday
blog post we recap
some of the major
milestones for BigQuery,
from the early days of community
support, as we figured out
how to apply SQL, to big data.
A major advantage to
BigQuery is that it
offers a choice
in pricing models,
so you can do big things on
whatever budget you have.
You can choose between the
entirely free BigQuery sandbox,
a pay-as-you-go approach
with on-demand pricing,
or flat-rate pricing
for dedicated resources.
Learn more about
your options and how
to decide which is best
for you in this blog post.
Finally, we've recently started
a new video series, BigQuery
Spotlight, to help you explore
the ins and outs of this fully
managed data warehouse.
Each topic is less
than five minutes
so that you can learn something
new, even in these busy times.
Check it out today, and be sure
to subscribe for notifications
on these future videos.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.